(upbeat music)
- Okay, welcome.
I'm Emily Conover,
Senior Physics Writer for Science News.
In honor of the hundredth
anniversary of our publication,
we are interviewing
some leaders in science
on some big questions.
I am delighted to be tackling
the topic of black holes
with Dr. Andrea Ghez
an astrophysicist at UCLA
and notably a winner of the
2020 Nobel Prize in Physics
for her work that unveiled
the supermassive black hole
at the center of our home
galaxy, the Milky Way.
Thanks so much for
speaking with me, Dr. Ghez.
- Oh, it's a pleasure to be here.
- So I think it's fair to say
that black holes are
having a moment right now.
On top of your own research
and the Nobel Prize,
we have the gravitational
wave observatories,
which in 2015,
first spotted two black holes
spiraling together and merging.
We have the first image
of a black hole silhouette
from the Event Horizon Telescope in 2019,
and lots of other, too many
exciting results to mention.
So I think it's really fitting
that we're talking about this
topic today and right now.
And I thought maybe to start,
for our viewers who might be
less familiar with black holes
or might only know them
from science fiction movies,
can you start by just
defining what a black hole is?
- Sure.
Black holes are remarkably
simple given the fact
that they really push our
understanding of physics forward
or challenge our understanding of physics.
So a black hole is very
simply a region of space
where the pull of gravity is so intense
that nothing can escape
it, not even light.
You can also think of it just as an object
whose mass is confined to zero volume.
And so the idea of density,
which is mass divided by volume,
that goes to infinity,
And that's like the big,
giant red arrow that says you don't have
your description of
physics correct right here.
- Yeah.
And that's sort of where
all the weird puzzles come in, right?
And your work in particular,
you focus on supermassive black holes,
one super massive black
hole in particular.
Can you talk a little bit
about the distinction between
these sort of super massive giant guys
and the smaller black holes?
- Sure. I mean,
in astrophysics we think of
two classes of black holes.
And in fact,
these two classes nicely demonstrate
the two ways in which
science is often done.
So the first ones that were
recognized or understood
are what we call the
stellar-mass black holes.
And they're the outcome of how stars
that start off their life
as very massive stars,
with more than 30 times
the mass of the sun,
are expected to end up,
so predicted by theory
and demonstrated
beautifully observationally
with the gravitational wave detectors.
The supermassive black
holes are much more massive,
as the name suggests.
So rather than being
on order of 10 times the mass of the sun,
they're more like
a million to a billion
times the mass of the sun.
And we think that they reside
at the center of galaxies,
so that each galaxy is thought to form
with one central supermassive black hole.
So these were found observationally,
and now we're on the hunt
to understand theoretically
how they formed.
- One thing you know, about
both types of black holes,
there's sort of this nexus
of lots of these really big questions
in physics and astronomy.
And they cover sort of
a variety of different
sort of sub-fields, right?
So you have a fundamental
tests of general relativity,
which is Einstein's theory of gravity.
Questions about how galaxies form,
you know, everything in between, right?
So I'm curious what you think,
what is the reason that
black holes in general
are such fruitful grounds for research
on such a variety of topics?
- Oh, that's an interesting question.
I mean, in the case of
fundamental physics,
which really crosses both
the stellar-mass black holes
and the supermassive black holes,
you really have very fundamental questions
about how our universe works.
We only have four known
forces and gravity is one.
It's the one we're most familiar with
in terms of our intuition here on earth.
You throw a ball up, it comes back down.
And yet it's actually the least
tested of the four forces.
So black holes provide this avenue
for furthering our understanding
of fundamental physics.
And in particular,
our inability at the moment
to bring together the two
fields of quantum mechanics,
which is the study of
things that are very small,
together with the field
of general relativity,
which is our best description
of how gravity works.
In the case of supermassive black holes,
these things reside at
the center of galaxies
where you have extreme environments
in many, many different ways.
I mean, not only is the
gravitational field extreme
because of the black hole itself,
but the centers of galaxies are extreme
in many other aspects,
such as the stellar density.
So people often refer to
the center of galaxies
as like the urban hub.
It's like, you know,
the center of New York City
and we're out in the half,
you know, we're halfway out in the galaxy.
So we're out in the calm suburbs.
But almost any way you
can describe a galaxy
becomes more extreme.
The magnetic fields, the winds,
just the activity in
general is really extreme.
So it means that you have
an opportunity to understand
the physical processes that are associated
with multiple aspects of a galaxy
in the extreme environment
of the center of galaxies.
So, in the case of the
supermassive black holes,
you get that extra layer
of trying to understand
not only the formation and
evolution of these galaxies,
which we think the black
hole plays a central role in,
but just physics,
sort of physics of the extremes.
- Yeah, that's great.
I know physicists always love
to look at the most extreme example
and use that to test their understanding.
So I think black holes
are definitely a good example of that.
Great.
So I'm curious if you could tell us
your sort of scientific origin story.
So what was it that originally
drew you into this topic?
Or how did you get started
with your fascination with black holes?
- Origin stories are always complicated,
astrophysically or otherwise.
So mine,
I can tell you a narrative
that will make sense,
but it wasn't actually as
clean as the narrative,
which I'll also share.
So the family lore is that
when I was four years old
and I do remember this,
the first moon landing was happening.
So I got excited about
thinking about the universe,
certainly started to stay
up late at night, wondering,
worrying about, you know,
the enormity, the
timescales, the boundary.
And the family legend is
I announced that I wanted to
be the first woman on the moon.
I mean today I joke, you
know, the job's still open.
But I certainly got more interested
in pursuing astrophysics from the ground.
But at the same time,
I also wanted to be a ballerina.
As little kids want to do,
they have multiple ideas about,
or ways of thinking about their future.
So while I got exposed to it early on
and was fascinated by it,
I wasn't singular or
certain in my path forward.
But what I do remember,
and I think really connects,
is that I've always been
interested in solving problems.
So ultimately my interest in
dance got into choreography,
which is basically a
problem-solving exercise
of how do you put this, you know,
this dance story together.
And I became very good at math.
So I actually went off to college
wanting to be a math major,
and soon discovered
it was much more esoteric than I thought.
And at that point I was quite
interested in black holes,
so I switched to physics
as maybe more an experimental approach
as opposed to a theoretical
approach to black holes.
- Great.
So when you were starting your work,
can you describe for us
what was sort of the scientific attitude
towards black holes?
You know, were people
confident that they existed
or was there still some question,
and then how did your work
sort of move that forward?
- Yeah. So when I started this project
there was definitely
the idea or the notion
that supermassive black holes
might exist at the center of galaxies.
And in particular,
the state of the field was that, you know,
there's a small class or
about 10% of all galaxies
have an unusual amount of energy
coming out from their centers.
They're called active galactic nuclei.
I mean, their name really says it all.
Their nuclei, or their
centers, are very active.
And it was hypothesized
that what was driving all this activity
was a super massive
black hole at the center,
so that would be the central engine.
And roughly at that same time,
people were asking
could it possibly be
true that all galaxies
harbor supermassive black holes?
And in the case of normal galaxies,
these are black holes that
are basically on a diet,
are lacking material falling
on to the black hole,
which is how we thought
the active galactic
nuclei were being powered.
But in our own case,
in the case of our own Milky Way,
the idea,
you know, our galaxy is an
ordinary, garden-variety galaxy,
nothing special about us.
The idea there is that
there was very little gas at the center.
And so perhaps this is a black
hole that was simply starved.
So that really offered,
I mean, that's what
also introduced the idea
that the Milky Way is a
great place to ask this
because it's the closest example
of a supermassive black hole
that we'll ever have to study.
The next closest one is a
hundred times further away.
Now, while there was that idea,
there were also some
counter-arguments to the idea
that our galaxy could harbor
a supermassive black hole,
or just that all galaxies
had supermassive black holes.
And that was that there
were very young stars
seen in the proximity,
not as close as we ended up looking,
but out at further distances.
So already, the existence
of these young stars
gave some trouble to the notion
that there was a black hole there,
because black holes produce
these very strong tidal forces.
So the idea that gravity
depends on distance,
so that the pull on one side of an object
is greater than the pull on
the other side of the object,
so much so that it just distorts
or pulls apart the object itself.
And stars,
baby stars start off
as very fragile clouds
of gas and dust.
So there was this problem
already that people said,
"Well, look, there's not enough gas
or dense enough gas to
overcome this problem."
So that's an argument
against the black hole.
So that's really where the argument was
in the early nineties, when we jumped in.
You know, a nice scenario
for why they should be there
and an argument against them.
So that was really the state of the field.
Although I should mention one other thing,
which is that we did know
that there was an unusual
radio source at the middle,
it's name is Sagittarius A*.
So Sagittarius
because it's in the
constellation of Sagittarius.
So if you look up at night
and you look for the
constellation of the tea cup,
it pours into the center of the galaxy.
So that's how you can find
the center of the galaxy
if you're out camping.
And A, because it was the
brightest radio source
and star, because people were
trying to be very clever.
They were borrowing notation
from nuclear physics
where the asterisk meant excited state.
So they were seeing gas that
didn't look like a star.
So it was Sag-A, really not a star.
So it's one of those names that's,
so we really should say
Sag-A, not a star. (laughs)
So they thought it was like a low,
very, very, very, very,
very, very faint equivalent
of the active galactic nuclei centers.
- Right.
So then you come in and
start looking at these stars
that are very close to the, you know,
Sag-A star, which you know,
at that point in time was not known
whether it was a supermassive
black hole or not.
How were you able to reveal
that in fact that is what
we were seeing there.
- So the idea of the work that we did
was that stars that are very close
should provide the most direct evidence
for a supermassive black
hole through their motions.
So if you can discover
stars that are there
and track their motion,
so basically watch their orbits,
these stars should orbit
the center of the galaxy
for the same reason that
planets orbit the sun.
So it's just gravity.
And each orbit tells you how
much mass is inside its orbit.
And then the size of
the scale of that orbit
tells you the region that
you can find the mass too.
So the proof of the black
hole is lots of mass
inside a very small volume or radius.
And in fact,
you'd like to get inside
the Schwarzschild radius,
'cause that's the point
at which gravity overcomes
all other known forces
and forces that mass
to become the infinitesimally small object
that we know of as a black hole.
So, you want to see stars
as close to the center of the galaxy.
So the first challenge was,
can we find them, can we discover them?
And since you want to get close,
you need to go to wavelengths
where you can see the starlight.
So radio wavelengths,
you don't see much light from the stars,
it's mostly dominated by the gas.
So we went to the infrared.
You can go to the optical or
the infrared to see starlight,
but at the center of the galaxy,
there's lots of dust between us
down the center of the galaxy.
And that dust is very good
at absorbing optical light,
what our eye detects.
So it's basically invisible
at optical wavelengths,
but if you go to the infrared,
you can see that starlight.
So that's why all our work
has been done in the infrared.
Next, you want to go to a big telescope.
The larger your telescope,
the better the angular resolution.
So you want to see stars
as close as possible,
so it's really important
that you get to high angular resolution.
So the larger the telescope in principle,
the smaller the scale
that you can actually see.
And the largest telescope in the world
that can see infrared light
right now is the Keck telescope.
This is out in Hawaii,
but it's on the ground,
and so you have to contend
with the atmosphere.
So the next challenge is you
have to beat the atmosphere.
And so that's what we we've
done a lot of work on,
is trying to figure out
how to beat the atmosphere
so that you can actually see these stars
and track their motions.
- Yeah, I have to say that
the videos that you've made
of showing this data over
decades of these stars
moving around the supermassive black hole,
they are so fascinating to watch.
I just love kind of marveling at the fact
that we can even see these stars
and measure them moving around this,
you know, extremely massive black hole.
It blows me away every time.
So I'm just curious,
when were you first able to see that
and, you know,
what was the feeling that you had
when you were first able to do that?
- Oh gosh.
So this actually goes back to
when I first joined the faculty at UCLA,
that was in 1994.
So I joined the faculty
because I really wanted
to do this experiment.
I wanted access to the Keck telescope.
Keck is co-owned by the
University of California
and Caltech,
so this to me was my dream job.
So I put my very first
proposal in, in 1994,
and it was turned down. (laughs)
So it was turned down
because people hadn't done this
diffraction-limited imaging
at Keck yet.
So you know,
there was a lot of skepticism
about whether or not Keck,
which is a segmented telescope,
could actually achieve
diffraction-limited resolution,
in spite of the fact that
it was designed to do so.
So it took us a year to convince people
that our approach would work.
So we started in 1995 as a result.
So the first thing we needed to do
was demonstrate that the
technique would work.
And in '90, I guess we
actually did that in '94.
We just had to prove that
the technique would work.
And then in '95, we
actually saw the images.
So you could prove that they could work,
this business works at
the center of the galaxy.
So that was really exciting in '95.
But you haven't seen the motion yet.
So the original approach
was just to see how things
move on the plane of the sky.
So you need two images.
So we did that in '96.
You have two points,
two points determine a line.
And, oh my goodness,
I cannot tell you how
exciting it was in 1996
to get that second image.
And of course, you know,
there are lots of
challenges along the way,
including the first night
in '96 was weathered out.
The second night, I think
we had instrument problems.
And it was the third time
we went in and actually got the data.
So there's nothing like
a little bit of obstacle
to make the success even sweeter.
We didn't publish until '97
because we actually wanted three points
to make sure we understood
how well we were doing,
because of course there
are lots of challenges
associated with making these measurements.
So it was '97
that we submitted our
first paper on doing this.
I'll say, actually,
I can say a little bit
more about that phase,
which was also interesting
but really fun because we only thought
we were going to do a
three-year experiment.
- Wow.
- So the original idea was
just to get the velocities,
'cause you can prove statistically,
you can use ensemble averages
or velocity dispersions rather,
to get the enclosed mass.
But at that point,
people were pushing back.
There was a lot of skepticism
that it wasn't actually a black hole.
And the particle physicists
got into the act at this point
and started suggesting
that there were other kinds
of objects it could be.
And in particular, the idea
that it could be a fermion ball.
So these are objects that are,
I guess they're like neutron stars.
So rather than being a
pure object of neutrons,
these are more primitive particles,
which means that it's more compact.
And there were also
suggestions that these objects,
the fast-moving stars that we
were seeing really close in,
weren't actually bound to
the center of the galaxy.
It was really fun.
I guess it was really fun at
this point in the experiment
because people were starting
to push back on the idea
that the velocities that were seeing
were from the black hole.
And you can do a freshman physics
calculation that tells you
that you should be soon
seeing the accelerations,
if this is indeed a black hole.
So we just kept going and soon enough,
things started to curve.
And at that point you can do
some again, simple things.
There were three stars that
showed the first accelerations
and each acceleration should point to
where the black hole is because
it's a central potential.
And the central potential
should be radial.
And even in projection,
you should get these
vectors that point to,
this is where the black hole is.
And so all of a sudden you
actually can show that this mass
is associated with that
unusual radio source,
Sag-A*, to a very high degree of accuracy.
And again, pushes you to the next level.
Because at that point,
you know that the orbit
should only be on order of 10 years long.
We'd been going for five years,
what's another five years?
And at that point, it was
clear that we should continue.
And people, even at that point,
were starting to anticipate
the power of these orbits.
That these orbits could show you
that not only that there was a black hole,
but could introduce new ways
of testing Einstein's theories
of general relativity.
So I have to say that paper,
the acceleration paper,
which came out in 2000,
was really a transformative moment.
I think that's at the point
that we really understood
how much science could come
from this sort of work.
It was really,
it was really an exciting moment.
- Yeah. And you're still of course
working on the same area, you know,
the center of the galaxy today, right?
So, I mean, I guess I'm
wondering, you know,
do you ever lose interest?
I mean, how does this keep
your attention for so long,
you know, from the '90s until now?
- Well, what's been so
fascinating about this
is there's been such evolution,
both in terms of the data themselves,
'cause you keep going.
And of course with the game
of orbits, time really helps.
The power of these measurements
increases dramatically with time.
But along the way,
we've also had the benefit
of advances in technology.
So after the first decade,
we moved from a very simple
approach of speckle imaging,
which only allowed us to take
images at a single wavelength
and that were not very deep,
to adaptive optics,
which was a much more powerful technique
and opened up new kinds of measurements.
And the most important was our
ability to get spectroscopy,
which gave us motion
along the third dimension
along our line of sight,
but also told us what kind
of stars we were looking at,
which revealed a host of new questions,
astrophysical questions.
And that along with being able
to take images at different wavelengths
just opened up many new questions.
So I think that's part of
what's been so fascinating
or captivating about this project,
is the continual opportunities
to go in new directions.
So while it seems like
we've been doing the
same thing all the time,
or for a long time,
more than two decades,
in fact,
the kinds of questions
that have been pursued
have changed quite dramatically over time.
- Right. Yeah going from, you know,
is there a supermassive
black hole there at all,
to can we test, you know,
does general relativity apply
near the supermassive black
hole, and so on, right?
- Yeah. Today we're looking at
black hole accretion physics.
We're looking at tidal interactions.
We're looking at star formation
in extreme environments.
We're looking at dynamical interactions.
I mean, among other things.
And of course the new test
of GR, really exciting.
And now we're on the hunt for dark matter.
So it's been an incredibly rich adventure.
- Well, it's interesting to me
because I think naively,
you might expect that black holes
would be sort of a dead end
because they're black and
you can't see inside them,
so you don't know what's going on, right?
But we've had so many
interesting observations, right?
To reveal more details of these objects
in all these different
inventive ways, right?
So I'm curious if you have any thoughts
about how we've been able
to make so much progress.
And do you think that people, you know,
when black holes first
appeared in physicist's minds,
do you think people expected
that we'd be able to understand
them as well as we do now?
- Well that's an interesting question
about what people understood.
I mean,
I think scientists are
incredibly optimistic in general.
I mean, I think for a long time,
there's an understanding that technology
is always going to drive
your understanding of science further.
So who knows? I mean,
I'm sure they didn't
imagine where we are today.
I mean, we couldn't,
we didn't even imagine where we were today
when we started this experiment.
So, you know, half a century ago.
But that's one of the
wonderful things about science
is it evolves so quickly.
I mean, and especially in an astrophysics.
I mean,
if we think about how far our
understanding of the universe
and all the phenomena that
are in it have evolved,
it's rather remarkable.
- Yeah.
It seems to be one of those situations
where black holes are just
so fascinating to physicists,
that they throw everything,
every technology,
every tool that might be
useful at understanding them.
And then we get some really
cool science out of that, so.
Well, as you mentioned earlier, you know,
when you were doing your measurements
and when you're beginning
to do these measurements,
no one had ever done them before, right?
I'm curious if you ever felt like
you were on the wrong track,
were you worried that
you might not succeed?
What was that like for you?
- Oh gosh, yes.
I mean I wish, quite frankly,
I wish I'd kept a diary
through this whole experiment
because it's been,
I guess today at 27 years
of lots of highs and lows
and uncertainty and
delight all along the way.
And there are definitely ebbs and flows
throughout this whole project.
I think there was a time
right before adaptive optics came online
and we were still in the speckle mode
where that wasn't, you know,
in some sense it's like we
were getting to the limit
of the return for speckle imaging.
And I think that was,
that was an interesting lull.
We did know adaptive optics was coming.
And, you know, we were
pushing forward on that front.
But you know,
it's always scary before a new technology
actually becomes
scientifically productive.
Is it actually going
to deliver the promise?
And I'd been working with
adaptive optics for 15 years
before it became
scientifically productive.
So, you know, you're never sure.
So I think that was one of
the really exciting things
about the Keck system,
is that unlike a lot of earlier systems,
it really was well-designed
in terms of doing something
that was technically robust
and scientifically mature,
rather than being just another step
in terms of technology development,
it became scientifically productive.
- You touched on this quickly earlier,
but I wanted to give you a chance
to go into a little more detail
about some of the new questions
that your research has opened up
and what big puzzles kind of
await that you're looking at.
- Oh, there are so many.
I mean, I love working
with new technologies
because new technologies give you
this very different view on the universe.
And often you're quite surprised
when you look at something
in a new and different way.
So some of the first problems
that we're still pursuing
actually hark back to
the original questioning
about supermassive black
holes from the young stars.
So the closest,
some of the closest stars
that we've discovered
to the supermassive black
hole are actually young.
So this exaggerates some
of the early concerns
or the tension between
the existence of a supermassive black hole
and the existence of young stars.
So the densities that you need
to overcome the tidal
forces from a black hole
scale as your distance cubed.
So if you bring your young
stars that you've discovered
from being quite farther,
far away to where we are today,
the densities required
are roughly 10 to the eighth times higher
that you need to overcome the tidal forces
than are seen today.
So I call that the tidal, sorry,
I call that the paradox of youth.
So understanding how you get young stars
in this extreme environment
is a really intriguing problem.
And it's been super interesting
because people have produced
theories for explaining this
from all different angles.
It's really,
it's inspired a lot of
theoretical thinking
and in three fundamentally different ways.
So one idea is that these
really are young stars,
but you formed them far away,
far away where the tidal
forces are really low.
So that requires you to think
about a dynamical process
that brings these young
stars in really quickly.
So you need some sort of express bus
in terms of physical processes
for migrating them in very quickly.
And that's actually quite difficult to do.
And you have to invoke an
intermediate mass black hole
between the supermassive and
the stellar-mass black holes.
So they may exist,
but we have yet to really
have ironclad evidence.
So that's a possibility,
although lots of questions.
Another idea is that maybe these things
that we're seeing as young stars
aren't young stars,
they're old stars which
are masquerading as youth.
And the idea there is,
that old stars have had lots of time
to form someplace else and migrate in.
So that's certainly a possibility.
And then the third possibility
is that these are young stars
that really formed where you see them,
so in situ,
and that the gas densities,
when they were being formed,
was much higher, you know,
by the 10 million or sorry,
a hundred million times
higher than we see today.
And as we kept making our
measurements of orbits,
there was an important signature
that evolved for these young stars
that were distributed
through this central region,
which is roughly half of the young stars
seem to reside in a disk,
so have orbits that all lined up.
So in fact, it looks a lot
like a scaled up solar system.
And so in fact,
you can borrow some ideas
from planet formation
or the formation of our own solar system,
where some of these
planets might've formed
out of an accretion disk
that existed at the time of formation.
And in fact,
this is the most popular idea today
for explaining the young stars
at the center of the galaxy,
is that our galaxy might've
had a very thick accretion disk
a few million years ago,
which would not only have
formed these young stars,
but also could have
supplied a reservoir of gas
to acreete on to the central black hole,
making our black hole
seem much more like an
active galactic nuclei
than it does today.
Suggesting that the whole galaxy
was much more active in
its youth than it is today.
Another mystery surrounds the old stars.
The old stars, as I mentioned before,
should be congregated
around the black hole
and should form something called a cusp,
an enhancement of their densities.
The local concentration of old stars
should be great near the
supermassive black hole.
And in fact,
we look for that concentration of light
that comes from that
enhancement of the crowding,
in other galaxies.
But we don't see that in the old stars.
We actually see a dearth of old stars
at the center of the galaxy.
And so that's been yet another mystery.
How do you explain this phenomena
that we think is a prediction
of having a super massive black hole
at the center of a galaxy that we rely on.
And that might have to do with,
there's again, a couple of ways out.
Either something dynamically
perturbed the galaxy
in the recent past.
So maybe we accreted a small galaxy
that messed up this local concentration,
or these old stars that we can see
were stripped of their outer atmospheres,
making them seem faint.
And then the last idea
is that the cusp resides in
objects that we can't see,
this is called the dark-cusp problem.
And that's an intriguing idea
that we're now trying to sort out
with the measurements of stellar orbits,
because that dark cusp
should actually impact
the way the stars orbit.
So that is a second very intriguing idea.
The third,
the third that I'll share
and I'll stop there,
but there's countless other directions,
is a class of objects
that were not predicted.
There were no predictions for these,
unlike the young and the old,
where we had clear predictions.
These are objects that
when they come through
their closest approach with a black hole,
they seem to be tidally distorted,
which is incredibly fun,
to be able to see things evolve over time.
So not only do we see stars
orbiting on a human timescale,
but we see these stars
become tidally elongated
as they get near the black hole
and then become compact again.
And this is surprising.
And this was only with the
advances of the ability
to see images at different wavelengths,
at longer wavelengths,
as well as the spectroscopy.
And what we think these are,
are objects that merged.
So most stars are actually
formed as binary stars.
If you put a binary
star near a black hole,
you get a three-body interaction
and that three-body interaction
could cause the binaries to merge.
And during that merger process,
what happens to the
star is it gets bloated,
gets really fat,
about a hundred times larger
than the other stars that we see,
the more typical, the
more anticipated stars.
And as that very bloated
star goes by the black hole,
it's large enough to experience
these tidal interactions
and have the outer shell
affected by the black hole.
And that's exciting.
And this one I find super intriguing
because it may be lighting up a process
that may explain one of the mysteries
associated with the
gravitational wave experiment.
So in LIGO and Virgo,
they're seeing objects
that are more massive than they expected.
So stellar-mass black holes
that are 30 times the mass of the sun,
rather than 10 times the mass of the sun.
And also occurring at a frequency
much higher than they expected.
So most stars are concentrated
towards the center of galaxies.
And if you think this
three-body interaction
is driving merger events,
and mergers are the underlying phenomena
that you see with gravitational waves,
you may be lighting up a process
that's really important for explaining
the source of gravitational wave emission.
So it's not that we're seeing
black holes merger products,
but a process that could be driving
stellar-mass black holes
that would also reside at
the center of galaxies.
So I'm intrigued by that
because it actually,
it's like when you see
something that you don't expect
in one field,
providing maybe a clue
to an unexplained answer in another area,
that's like unlocking multiple secrets.
So I'm intrigued by that third
problem that we see today.
- Yeah. That's really fascinating.
I love how,
and this is sort of what I
mentioned at the beginning,
is that these black holes,
the questions, you know,
connect to so many different
other areas of research.
And it's also just so fascinating to me
that we can use this kind of research
to understand what our
galaxy was like in the past,
understand the history of, you know,
where we are and you know,
what our galaxy was like before.
Just so many big questions.
It's really fun, really interesting.
- It has been,
it's been an amazing journey to understand
what we can understand at
the center of the galaxy.
And I think we have a
lot to be thankful for
in terms of the remarkable progress
that's been made technologically,
that's opened up our ability
to see this really fascinating region.
- Well, I'm curious what you think
our future conception
of black holes will be.
I mean, will we have to revise
what we understand about them
as we keep learning more, do you think?
- Oh, absolutely.
I mean, I think as scientists,
we're so drawn to things
that we don't understand
or where our models are limited,
because those are the places
where there's the most opportunity
to advance our understanding of physics.
So black holes definitely
represent the limitation
or the frontier of our knowledge.
And without a doubt, we
will be making progress.
There are so many new technologies
that are emerging at the moment,
not only, you know,
with our ability to see the
stars with adaptive optics,
with our ability to
see gravitational waves
through LIGO and Virgo,
as well as the Event Horizon telescope.
But we have LISA to look forward,
the space-based
gravitational wave detector,
which should open up the ability
to study the supermassive black holes
with gravitational waves,
where the ground-based
gravitational wave experiments
are really focused on
or sensitive to the
stellar-mass black holes.
So I think that will
be remarkably exciting.
And then in my own area,
I'm extremely excited about
the next generation of large
ground-based telescopes.
So the 30 meter telescope,
as it will allow us to
see the full population.
I mean, today we can only
see the brightest stars
at the center of the galaxy.
And the way I like to explain
what I think the potential is,
is it's like I'm trying
to understand the economy
by only being able to see
the largest transactions,
which are big,
but few and far between
compared to the smaller,
but more frequent interactions.
So, same things with the stars.
There are lots of faint stars
and very few bright stars.
So today we can only
see the brightest stars
because they're separated
by larger distances.
And the fainter stars
become lost in the confusion
of the stellar density.
So at higher resolution
that these next-generation
telescopes should afford us,
we'll be able to see beyond
the tip of the iceberg
and see those common everyday stars.
And in particular,
we'll be able to see stars like the sun
to understand really the
full range of activity
that resides at the center of the galaxy.
- Well, that's very exciting.
It seems like there's a bright
future for this kind of work.
I'm curious,
what's your advice to young people
who are fascinated by black holes
and want to go on to study them?
- Oh, my advice to young people in general
is find out what excites you,
where your passion is, and pursue it.
Anything that's interesting
is going to be hard,
interesting and not already done is hard.
So when you have passion for something,
it'll motivate you to overcome
the inevitable obstacles that
you'll face along the way.
- Andrea, thank you so
much for talking with me.
It's been really fascinating.
And for the viewers,
you can keep up with the latest
discoveries in astrophysics
by visiting us at sciencenews.org
and connecting with us on social media.
Thanks for joining us.
(upbeat music)